what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries at free Quinton
Tarantino movie movie our thought
process behind the trailer you'll get to
see some deleted scenes at the end will
respond to questions from viewers like
you and we will tease next week's
trailer I'm sitting here with Joe lon
Dan me we're back from break we're
feeling refreshed full of vigor and yet
we turned this one in right before the
break we're all exhausted but it's good
to see it again it came out great yeah
if I'm going to pad all of us on the
back I think as we should really went
Randy our editor Randy who worked on
this one with the break and Kevin who
brought it home should should get the
pens
the creators of the the feat song yes
yes Matt Citrone our go to some debate
we can maybe get to it later that foot
song was too long and that we wouldn't
have enough feet for it we did turns out
was the one behind you and there was one
set of footprints there were enough feet
it was interesting like when it was
still theoretical we were all like the
first time the song played so it was a
fun exercise I don't know we all kind of
split up the movies and kind of picked
three not really at random we did like a
round-robin draft hatefully it went
weirdly early long I had only ever seen
hateful eight like in the theater during
the road show and then I never rewatched
it been already kind of thinking like
I'd like to revisit hateful eight so it
was a perfect up at the end but we all
kind of dabbled in like you know
different periods of his career and SEP
14 yellow who was not present
much like this commentary was cut from
the trailer everything well she wasn't
there the day we did the draft so she
didn't get the pic and we gave her all
the things he didn't do officially I
guess stuff his student films almost
entirely from the trailer yeah I'm
seeing a lot of comments being like did
you know he also made an episode of ER
dare you get this yeah but I feel like
that's a fewer number of people did that
then if we had put those things in and
they were like what the hell is this the
Mentalist yeah but yeah I think like I
don't know I had a good time going back
through the filmography yeah he likes to
give the audience a good time redoing
Kill Bill was super fun I didn't think
that I would like those as much as I did
but man they should have been one movie
I think they should have been one three
and a half hour long movie but it was so
good I love Kill Bill I both were good
he you had me you lost me you had me
filmmaker cuz yeah so on board with his
early stuff and then I really liked Kill
Bill and the death Proof I was like oh
no like he's gone what are you doing
legally up to the but of the 70s and
we're never gonna get him back homage is
that only he gets for the rest of his
career and then he came out and made
what I think are his for three of his
four best films ever in a row I like
hateful eight more than most but I
wouldn't put it up there necessarily was
like killed with a Pulp Fiction well but
three I think of his four best films
ever made right in a row so there you go
yeah well death Proof was my hateful
eight where I was like I haven't seen
this since they did the whole fun grind
house release and maybe it's not as
rough as I remember and let's let's give
it a look-see and yeah that could have
been a really great 15 minute short
filming what
I think it's I appreciate what he's
doing that cuz like he's he's riffing on
movies that have the same problem that
d'esprit fast like he's roofing how
movies have a great opening set up and
then there's like 30 40 minutes of
filler in the middle where they just
kind of have to have a lot of talking's
they ran out of money and then it's got
like a big action climax a wonderful you
can tell he's doing that but it doesn't
make it less frustrating to watch it's
like telling a joke that you've had to
be there to understand like I get that
you're doing that it's just that I you
know for that 500 other people in the
country have enough knowledge and
appreciation for this genre to
understand the joke where that with the
bit or whatever so it's it's it's lost
on ya because there's a lot of movies
like bad sort of Zee great homemade 70s
grindhouse movies do do that we're like
they're introduced a group they all get
massacred and then you've got like this
long like well we got to meet the new
group and then they're driving to this
motel and I drop deep cut Dinobot jokes
around you guys it's I think my favorite
one or at least the one where I'm like
the most excited and promised for the
future of his career which makes it such
a weird decision that he's ending
because I feel like he's finally
creating his own characters instead of
having them be like these pest issues of
other movie heroes that he's kind of
cobbled together yeah like he's doing
character based stuff plus all the
Tarantino actions to be like so I just
hate that he's got so much freedom now
like only a few people could have made
once upon a time in Hollywood like with
those level of movie stars and yeah it's
a rambling like kind of not plot heavy
3-hour original idea and it's yeah I'd
be ashamed to lose him just because how
many people are even doing work like
that right now like only a handful yeah
yeah keep working for our enjoyment yeah
enjoy your life if you honest trailer
for Once Upon a Time in Hollywood well
and whatever
yeah the eight to nine out of it
[Music]
deep from the heart of a crying house
theater one filmmaker will rise from
video store clerk to the guy video store
clerks worship and answer the question
what were the love child of the 90s the
seventies comic books kung-fu movies and
cocaine look like this world of classic
cinema and attention deficit disorder
where the smoke is heavy the voices are
probably plays grizzled the best but if
you've ever seen an interview with him
he's not he's actually very not a very
Unger is Alyssa yeah in real life but I
think he plays grizzled I mean clay
Bennett's would anyone genuinely gristle
is the mobile personal waiter from that
SNL sketch Robert Duvall still with us
still be your champion did win that
sketch with the answer I once drove a
team of horses up Bear Mountain good
stuff
looking for wistful that was scorned or
MacDonald sketches for 500 Alex yep all
right keep going always agree I'm hungry
until now pause I think do you think
this is because he writes his
screenplays I don't if he still does he
probably has a home now
at TOI TOI that the Thai restaurant on
sunset it's open like 24 hours maybe
he's right he likes to write about what
people talk about and yeah what most
people talk about is food that's gonna I
say I think he's so much about defining
characters by what they like and what
they enjoy and their routines and I
think that's why you get into a lot of
like ding and coffee and tacos and you
know yeah
realism yeah well I mean how how often
have you had a life-altering intense
oscar-worthy conversation over diner
food like that's why I like that's just
like Bacon's tasty you're eating a
Denver omelet in the next minute
someone's taking a gun even yeah all
right keep going
the most appetizing by the way of
Tarantino's foods I would eat that
strudel strudel hands-on experience all
three phases of qts career the
critically acclaimed crime trilogy the
unjust gonna make 70s movies phase the
really long one as funny as this may or
may not be we did say three phases and
we said the three phases and three lives
yeah sorry and revisionist history we
want to end up like
[Music]
and I hope you like them all because
he's only one movie away from retirement
oh crap really it gave me right let's
see Kent the kill bills is one movie
death rope is too short account for a
full one Jackie Brown is an adaptation
so Esther sax that one too there we go
he's only for movies away from
retirement surplus Harry I don't know
our math is long do we think they wanted
to go home do we think he's really going
to retire after one more movie I respect
the confidence to know that you're going
to be such an important director that
you can make this a big deal yeah what's
film that he announced it was 10 after
what film I feel like it was Django it
was right around jingo hateful eight was
like do it now because it's right and
yeah I think it was around Django times
I feel like yeah okay that's a little
more of a sure thing where you're like I
can make this important for some reason
I thought it was like after like Jackie
Brown what's interesting is that was a
hateful eight as well that he started as
a novel or he started as a book or maybe
it was a play or something like that I
think he started as a play and then once
upon a time he started as a book yeah so
he could just like he could stop being a
filmmaker he's gonna retire after one
more but he's so obsessed with like
Sergio Leone and all of these old-school
filmmakers that like we're making movies
into their 80s I think she didn't retire
for five or ten years and he's gonna
come back as like an elders and elder
statesman yeah and yeah I think he's
gonna carry on as as a novelist but it's
all gonna be just in his voice yeah the
guy
the samurai walks into the room he looks
over there it is like a bunch of ninjas
this really cool song starts playing
[Music]
he's gonna retire for a time and then I
feel like it's gonna be like one of
these like sports retirements like wait
2 or 3 years people get excited a little
baseball yeah TV try mmm a CSI coming or
maybe you like just [ __ ] like like
Herzog start doing documentaries or
something documentary Wow you know like
you know like those those Scorsese does
document like like my voyage to Italy
and it's like yeah we were talking about
the almost tragedy like if things had
gone the other way there's a sliding
door situation where he just like a
terrible rockabilly band there we go
he's only for movies away from
retirement Hugh lead a Tarantino main
character they're probably involved in a
life of crime and they're definitely up
to date on what ever dated pop culture
references are rolling around in his
head you know like Cain and conch phone
silly rabbit tricks are for kids like a
virgin Valley of the dolls
you remember Fantastic Four the Delphi
bellboy with Jerry Lewis Mannix
that's from film and Batman involving
pee oh do you know any of these shows of
people I'm talking about when they
suffer a horrible injustice they'll put
on a cool outfit
drive around talking you know what they
call
a quarter pounder with cheese drive
around listening to music and drive
around talking while listening to music
as they go undercover we'll be putting
on an act and find themselves in a
high-stakes conversation where someone
is not who they say they are one of them
felt is not what he said he's us cops
until the whole thing turns into one big
standoff and a huge one intramural mess
broke for a second yeah so he wrote true
romance and dusk till dawn that's our
boy killers not born killers and then
doesn't you have like or is that just
weed and for like with speed where it's
like Oh Tootie did like a punch up on oh
yeah we did
Crimson Tide yeah and there's that one
scene where they all talk about Silver
Surfer
[Music]
I don't know that scene I think so but I
definitely know he did just sounded like
a Patton Oswalt joke there is a scene
where Denzel Washington out of context
use the Silver Surfer as an elaborate
metaphor yes it's gotta be phrased Joss
Whedon in speed or you start talking
about Gigantor out of nowhere yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I wonder if there's other
movies out there like that
probably untranslated up datapath
tarantino pop-culture do you think
cuties done passes on Josif stuff and
that's why all of his heroines have bare
feet most of them do serenity girl
always walking around yeah Buffy not a
lot of shoes to dig you stuff okay the
husers say it
the next level heaven take the shoes off
man okay okay okay okay okay take the
shoes off man you opened under okay okay
you would have anybody said confused
until it's a badass family school play
rebel in this one-of-a-kind filmmakers
brilliant dialogue sharply drawn
characters timeless soundtracks in that
the songs are from the same era as the
movie and depending on how you feel
about him either his incredible talent
for remix in Ematic history or
incredible audacity to jack the kueh
shots from old movies for himself it's
not stealing if you haven't seen it just
as Lucas for PTA or Guy Ritchie or all
of them charge levied against him and I
think he is I don't know he maybe does
less so often in particular as because I
think he leaned maybe even heavier on
sitting on fire that
well then homage but it also had his
dialogue
you kind of got branded it I mean that
was sort of sorry let me restart the
sentence by not saying it was someone's
brand Jesus his content is really
content he was the fan and so I think
automatically people just start looking
for it like oh he's the he's the the
video clerk nerd started making remaking
his favorite movies it's just also the
incorrect idea like there's a cliche out
there a trope that the hard part of
creating something like these movies is
the idea or coming up with the idea of
the shot or the idea for the scene like
oh you just stole that idea from another
movie that's the easy part
and turning those ideas and images into
something like Reservoir Dogs fiction
that people remember and love as their
own thing that's very difficult so yeah
it doesn't matter that he's kind of
riffing on these old ideas that's they
can't turn it into Jackie Brown he's
stealing from things more interesting
than most movies are stealing from kind
of bland yeah shot reverse shot I think
he's now hit the perfect hybrid I think
that he is still showing the influence
of these movies that he loves but
they're now again I think post death
Proof wholly original as far as his
voice his autism yeah you know he may
still be referencing but I feel like
it's it's it's a lot more of his eye and
a lot less of his eye reflected through
the eyes of other filmmakers like that's
what his evolution has been and you see
that was a lot of fun I think also if
you look at once upon a time doing a lot
of these images and references has made
him a virtuoso at copping any other
style I mean he can recreate a TV
Western an Italian police film like
their own Oh perfect master like frame
everything to like evoke all these
different eras and styles and film my
favorite thing about Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and I don't know how many
other people caught up to but it's this
thing of just having that eye is even
that opening interview between later an
DiCaprio Brad Pitt thinks and the
interview us it's not just that it's
done in the style of an old 1960s 50s TV
interview it's that he replicates the
way that they were shot which was there
was a camera that was
pointed and they did all of the all of
the interview with Brad Pitt and Lina
DiCaprio's characters and then they
would turn the camera back on the
interviewer and shoot him asking the
questions individually and then they
would edit it together and it he did
that so he replicated it he replicated
because you could tell that he was
shooting it like it was shot as two
different pieces of film the way he
directed the actor to sort of ask the
questions but in an open-minded way his
eyes eyelines were never quite there the
pauses like he's got an eye now to like
even when he's replicating something he
knows how to fold that into such an
interest in service of a story yeah
exactly
Wow I wish you start making movies now
instead of ten years ago or ten movies
ago yeah but if you came out with
Reservoir Dogs and Pulp Fiction today
like we only have the world we have
today and the movies we have today
because that happens in the nineties
hope fix you came out today that kitchen
scene would have ended from the cultural
mores I just mean like who knows what
kinds of movies we'd even be going to
see today without Tang Tina 20 is
probably the big hit part 8 the big hit
franchise keep making movies we'd still
be watching disaster movie probably all
right keep going
so salud a living legend who made some
of the best films of a generation while
influencing some of the worst films of a
generation grid because we got a lot of
defenders first smokin aces the best
movie on that grid
fine and I'm just really glad we made
Dan you you you pushed us in this
directions - yeah and I was gonna push
back we took off go and we took off okay
boo duck taints okay Hey terrible movie
that's not saved by an insane willem
dafoe performance but i know we all had
the poster on our dorm in college so a
lot of people did but not me regardless
of our own opinions I knew that if we
put Boondock Saints in that grid we
would be the there would be a booed be a
boondock comments section is like we
don't want that it's all of the comments
Boondock Saints all of our works gonna
be wasted so just get rid of Doc's like
I even saw some people going to bed for
reindeer games movie is someone else's
thank you
there was a blonde highlights Jenko
jeans wearing version of me that was
very angry at the idea of go being
included in this list
yes mocha nice is that surprised me yeah
I I would not I would have picked away
the gun people were gonna come in and
really defending but not go figure
smokin aces I might have ranked last so
there you go yeah well I didn't even
know people liked it honest like I
didn't anticipate any pushback on her
legs apparently with a primary like a
featured central role for Jeremy Piven
we'd be over by now
pithos on hard not what women in black
people amazing badass characters to
cheer for and he also gave a bunch of
white guys an n-word pass ethological
the amount of n words he has in his
movies at least with Django you can make
some justification that's probably not a
conversation the for emotion even I am
just like right the only two were
there's any historical context to it you
could still do it less if you wanted to
but right
yeah he's no excuse for like people
coming out of the woodwork to be like I
and my friends say it all the time
reconsider yeah there you go keep God
but he would sure and one of the best
filmmakers in Hollywood history but it's
thanks to the tireless work of one of
the worst people in Hollywood history
but one thing's always been clear
uncontroversial and unanimous about
Quentin Tarantino this man loves a good
food and sing along every other words
[Music]
don't tell with the spoken word of any
atomic test yeah Randy inspire you I can
get y'all fellas yeah yeah my take me
down to anything I don't be tickling
enough
do we need assessments
[Music]
yeah that's message tones voice
I'm painting with feet no it's tourists
samuel l jackson michael Batson
Christoph Waltz when he wants an Oscar
Ruby stars rising stars fading stars
chapters trunk shots red apple
cigarettes that's the way the rich
should taste spitting I never noticed
this so much I spent being all gross
torture one word assassin but imagine
cruel they're brothers endured at our
hands extreme close-ups
a movie within the movie
Austin Powers and himself yeah but I
have a foot fetish so it kind of even
itself a student family it was all a
Tarantino movie and pawpaws Robert
Robert Hopi fer ya here's what happens
when you do one of these things and it's
this repeats itself every time we'll say
like he'll be like what would you like
to do and we're like you know what maybe
just get like a vibe like maybe pulp
fiction like just you know give us the
Tarantino vibe and that would be
wonderful and he'll then you'll get nine
different treatments as we did he did in
every Quentin Tarantino movie and the
style every single Quint ain't in the
movie individually which is why we
wanted to cycle through all of them as
much as we could and share them because
he was amazing and that's that's just
not just that because you'll be like how
about just like a general vibe and he'll
be like I could do all of them like he's
like I mean I could I won't sleep for
two weeks find a font that kind of looks
the last thing I did 30 minutes before
we exported it was almost half-assed
thing or Jumanji the 90s when he like
recreated the entire bullet out of like
the individual particles that I worked
on and I was like does he do stuff like
this every time this my nephew's
christening but thank you Robert okay
that's like a Jacob Marley goes every
week I don't have to care has to do like
ten ones in a few weeks when we do the
Oscars so
yeah no way around that it's just times
new roman' all right do you have any
deleted scenes sir tag no we do no
desert tag Larry did you know that
Quentin Tarantino also directed an
episode of ER it's the one where he and
dr. Ross go to Mexico and kill a bunch
of vampires all right I'll just reenact
the things that we cut we had a joke
about him repeating himself that like
that was a little formulaic then
everyone has the same kind of
overarching structure that we record
that it was that just in there I missed
the first cousins for it let's do
something
wooshii o01 writes my favorite new CEO
score says Tarantino Fincher Nolan what
other living film directors do you
consider to be highly consistent
throughout their whole careers Spielberg
and Eastwood are good but have enough
stinkers for me not to consider them
consistently great anyone in there I
mean the Coen brothers to me are some of
the most consistent like crazy about but
almost always they're amazing yeah I
would have them in there it's
challenging to as body of work increases
because it's like sure Spielberg's made
some stinkers Spielberg's also made a
lot more movies than Fincher you know
the total times a plate how many times
they you know Scorsese yep says he I
think oh yeah remarkably you know us you
have New York New York that's what
everyone always says like Scorsese like
you know what about New York like yeah
what about the 14 other ones I can name
that are New York New York
I think he's remarkably consistent yeah
I mean I think like Scorsese there are
some like misses that aren't
as good as like the best Scorsese right
even his missus are interesting bringing
out the dead
definitely not top-tier Scorsese but
like it's an interesting movie I don't
hate it
Catherine yeah of other people it's like
a long enough thought least three four
four right Johnson okay brick bronze
bloom I'd take looper three four five
yeah though his though it's a key and I
find it not as fun or funny to watch me
work what do you Alan very consistent no
a lot of consistency movie as a younger
man like if we had this conversation in
like the deconstructing Harry era I'd be
like yeah how is he doing it they're all
still great since then post small-time
crooks I feel like we really kind of
fell off a I would say never made a bad
not alive he's doing great so far yeah
yeah alright well there you moving on
just in Chloe writes love the honest
trailer do you think he'll actually only
stick to ten movies we cover that moving
on Led Zep X is Tarantino Star Trek
still a thing I think they're saying
it's awesome because that would be
really fun just I know Dan you have a
complicated you know I'd be interested
yeah curiosity but at least to read the
script like what would he have done with
the Star Trek remake script yeah with no
shoes on that people are like well it's
just tone Elyse are different from what
he normally does but he can't like
Jackie Brown has a lot of his life
it's got Tarantino flavor but it's he
could do something that's like a tonal
departure and as someone that's obsessed
with the seventies yeah sure he was
watching Star Trek every night I think
it's I think it's under estimate or yeah
I think it's under estimating him to say
that he couldn't take all of his like
weird quirky cute eNOS and sort of put
it to one side and make something that's
of that franchise that it comes from I
think he could probably do it captain
initial scan show an earth-like planet
only it appears that they never invented
shoes Society so you can save as much as
you want that's right well there you go
that's all the questions you guys had a
lot of other smokin aces stuff that we
are Larry talk about you smoke nation a
lot of crack doesn't cry next week we're
back we're back from vacation where we
will be back next week with another
multi film exploration and I don't know
what you're gonna do don't know what
you're gonna do don't what are you going
to what are you going to do next week
well you'll find out to see you next
week Austria commentaries thanks for
watching
[Music]
you